y'all watch the VMAs recently and watch
Miley Cyrus twerk that was a damn shame
not the fact that she look like an idiot
but the girls talking without a ass does
that make sense to you okay I think
that's like in the 12 commandments thou
shalt not work without booty cheeks oh
oh what is going on YouTube now as you
grow up you start to realize that in
your social group among your peers
everybody starts to like to drink now if
you guys have watched my previous videos
you guys already know and I'm not that
big of a drinker the [ __ ] that drunk
people do annoys the [ __ ] out of me
number one drunk people are always all
up in your personal Bowl the reason why
this happens is because when you're
drunk your depth perception gets all
messed up and because they're drunk
they're so close to you you think
they're gonna whisper wrong [ __ ] take
the same [ __ ] and allow the volume this
close to your face hey can I tell you
something number two I don't like drunk
people because I'm always a subtle one
having to take care of everybody else
here's a general rule if you're fat and
you're gonna get drunk and pass out in
the middle of the street [ __ ] you on
your own I'm gonna tell you straight up
right now I am not responsible for you
and you just might wake up with a dildo
in your [ __ ]
Heidi won't be 350 pounds and look at me
like I'm supposed to do something with
that stupid s look on your face haha
biggie stands for designated driver not
drunk daycare [ __ ] take care y'all
got themselves if you can stand you
could live you can walk I can take you
to the car and I'm driving your ass home
if you're sleeping and you're knocked
out in the middle of a dark alleyway
tighten your booty up cuz you might wake
up [ __ ] number three I don't want to
drug people that be getting violent all
the time every time you go out with this
one specific person that gets drunk he
always has to start [ __ ] with somebody
else at the time it's Oh another two
isn't it you're bringing my [ __ ]
oxygen bro and sometimes they're so
drunk is about the stupid [ __ ] you've
ever witnessed Hey the hell is that
looking at me over there oh that's your
reflection man
Oh reflection will you tell reflection
to go suck a dick I don't know if this
is like a college frat thing but every
time without fail I always seem so kind
of subdued they go suck it dick I think
that's like the go to drunk insult [ __ ]
you suffer cop bro but you ain't never
seen a sham sham knocked out who's their
Mateen dog can I ask you something
wouldn't you be gay if you ask somebody
else
is that just me let me tell you
something if you get into a fight I'm
not backing this up because I'm sober
two homeboys you're not the [ __ ] out I'm
a you crying we [ __ ] my pants
that's nothing look not before drum
people always love to use the fact that
they were drunk as an excuse for
everything so you're telling me if you
were drunk every day you could use that
as a logical explanation to explain why
you're a dumb [ __ ] baby did you feed the
kids [ __ ] I'm drunk it's my bad dog out
of you whether you're drunk enough you
are solely responsible for your actions
do you have any idea how messed up is
what would be if we could use
intoxication as an excuse for everything
North Korea shot a missile into the
ocean Kim jong-un what is your excuse I
having the two mattress torture I was
drunk
well okay then all right drunk people
somehow always managed not to pay for
the tab and guess who stuck with it the
didi the designated dumbass listen you
cannot be so drunk where you can't
remember that you have to pay for the
[ __ ] that you bought cuz you've got to
realize that this [ __ ] only happens with
that drunk person is either broke or
their ghetto I thought you got it man
I'm out peace [ __ ] baby just [ __ ] [ __ ]
why don't I somebody lies it was always
gotta get hella hot piss and [ __ ] you
didn't do nothing no bitching your boys
got any higher a bird would land right
on your face ah you know conversely when
rich people get drunk they always want
to pay for everything which I do not
mind hey no no it's on me and if you're
Asian you just kind of pretend like you
want to pay no no no no Peter let us a
pay no no I got it I got it
it's on me I love you guys no okay okay
you see you next time you see me okay
the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]